ja und der Generalsekretär der
Welthungerhilfe ist zu dem Thema zu uns
ins Studio gekommen schönen guten Morgen
Matthias Mucke guten Morgen sie stellen
heute ihren Jahresbericht für 2021 vor
zuerst wollen wir aber noch mal auf das
schauen was wir gerade eben im Beitrag
gesehen haben Ostafrika da ist die Lage
ziemlich schwierig ist das Ganze
exemplarisch für den Großteil des
afrikanischen Kontinents exemplarisch
würde ich nicht sagen die Lage in
Ostafrika ist schon ganz besonders
schlimm weil es eben vier Jahre ohne
Wasser dort gegeben hat und deswegen
leiden die Menschen dort ganz besonders
über 14 Millionen Menschen sind im
Moment auf Nahrungsmittel angewiesen es
gibt andere Regionen da ist das große
Problem Konflikte zum Beispiel
Vertreibung von Menschen was was zu
Hunger führt ja also deswegen die großen
hungertreiber sind Konflikte und ist der
Klimawandel die hungertreiber sind
unterschiedliche aber auf jeden Fall
haben alle das gleiche Problem nämlich
den Hunger schauen wir mal auf ihren
Jahresbericht wie fällt denn ihre
Gesamtbilanz für 2021 aus wir sind sehr
froh dass wir 260 Millionen Euro für
Projekte ausgeben konnten im letzten
Jahr die Hälfte davon tatsächlich auch
für humanitäre Hilfe für Nothilfe die
andere Hälfte und da sind wir sehr froh
drüber auch für langfristige Projekte
Aufbau von Widerstandsfähigkeit von
Menschen weil es bringt ja nichts immer
nur Nothilfe zu geben wir müssen
natürlich auch dafür sorgen dass
Menschen langfristig auch mit diesen
Widrigkeiten des Klimawandels umgehen
können Beispiel für so ein Projekt in
langfristiges auf jeden Fall es gibt zum
Beispiel ein eine Initiative nennt sich
Community Smart Village ist nutrition
Smart villages und nennt sich das und da
versuchen wir gerade Aufklärungsarbeit
zu machen gerade mit Frauen zum Beispiel
wie sie sich besser ernähren können wie
sie zu Hause auch Gemüsegärten anlegen
können um die Ernährung ihrer Kinder
lang zu verbessern jetzt haben wir das
Problem mit dem fehlenden Weizen
beispielsweise eine Folge des
ukraine-konfliktes dass der Weizen dort
nicht hinkommt jetzt sagt zum Beispiel
die
Ministerin bei uns Frau Schulze die
entwicklungsministerin man müsse
sozusagen den Ländern zeigen dass sie
ihr eigenes Getreide anbauen ist das
auch dann sozusagen ein Konzept was die
verfolgen auf jeden Fall also ich glaube
wir müssen die Ernährungssouveränität
also die Möglichkeit selber anzubauen in
den Ländern verstärken deswegen fordern
wir auch immer wieder langfristige
Investitionen in den ländlichen Raum in
die Landwirtschaft
Reduzierung von nahrungsmittelverlusten
zum Beispiel aufgrund mangelnder
Infrastruktur Straßen Kühlhäuser Märkte
und ich glaube da kann man nach wie vor
sehr sehr viel machen um die Ernährung
vor Ort zu verbessern das ist jetzt in
grundsätzliches Problem was wir auf der
einen Seite haben zusätzlich kommt der
Krieg in der Ukraine die russische
Führung verknappt ja die Nahrungsmittel
indem sie sie nicht rauslässt also quasi
ja Hunger als Druckmittel was kann die
Weltgemeinschaft darüber hinaus außer
das was sie jetzt gesagt haben noch tun
um sozusagen dem Hunger entgegen zu
treten wichtig ist dass die Märkte offen
bleiben dass nicht plötzlich jetzt alle
Länder anfangen ihre Grenzen zu
schließen für nahrungsmittelexporte zum
Beispiel wie wir es immer wieder sehen
also wir sehen eine steile Kurve immer
mehr Länder sagen wir lassen nichts mehr
raus das führt zu Verknappung dass
treibt die Preise nach oben und das ist
für die ärmsten Menschen auf dieser Welt
ganz ganz schlimm weil sie können sich
keine Nahrungsmittel mehr leisten das
ist im Moment das große Problem der
Zugang zu Nahrungsmittel wird für
Milliarden muss man sagen Menschen immer
weiter erschwert jetzt sind sie als
Hilfsorganisation auf Gelder angewiesen
auf Spenden wir haben eben schon gesagt
ja durch die Ukraine Frauen viele
dorthin Spenden viele auch dorthin und
vielleicht nicht sozusagen zur Welt
Hungerhilfe wie groß ist dieses Problem
wir sind erstmal sehr sehr dankbar dass
durch die pandemiezeit hindurch aber
auch jetzt während des Krieges in der
Ukraine die Solidarität mit den
Problemen im globalen Süden weiterhin
sehr sehr stark ist wir bekommen
weiterhin Spenden dafür sind wir sehr
sehr dankbar und wir hoffen einfach auch
dass die Menschen in Deutschland und wie
gesagt das ist die Erfahrung die wir
bisher haben solidarisch bleiben und
auch weiterhin Menschen im globalen
Süden daran denken und uns auch
weiterhin Spenden geben sagt der
Geschäftsführer der Welthungerhilfe
Matthias vielen Dank für das Interview
ich danke Ihnen